-Ses campagnes électorales
ressemblent
à une tournée des Rolling Stones.
Pékin, Melbourne, Tokyo,
ou encore Moscou,
mon invitée
représente une partie
des Français
établis à l'étranger.
Elle est députée de la plus grande
des 577 circonscriptions.
Générique
...
Bonjour, Anne Genetet.
-Bonjour.
-Enfant, vous avez eu
une discussion avec votre père
sur le sens de la vie
et la réponse
qu'il vous a faite
vous a marquée.
Qu'est-ce qu'il vous a dit ?
-Il m'a dit : "Je ne sais pas."
"Je pense qu'on est
comme un grand mur de briques
"et chacun d'entre nous
est une brique, et une brique,
"ça soutient les autres,
les faibles.
"Si un jour, t'as un coup de mou,
les autres
"te soutiendront,
donc sois une bonne brique.
-Donc ça,
c'est une belle image.
-Ca m'a portée constamment depuis
et j'espère l'avoir transmis
à mes enfants.
-Si on regarde votre parcours,
vous avez été
plusieurs briques différentes.
Vous avez été pédiatre,
journaliste santé,
consultante en gestion
de crise sanitaire,
blogueuse, également.
Vous avez la bougeotte ?
Vous avez besoin de changer
de vie, de métier,
régulièrement ?
-Quand j'ai fait le tour d'un sujet,
j'aime pouvoir en changer
quand l'opportunité se présente.
J'aime faire le tour
et savoir
que je peux être utile.
Quand j'arrive au bout
de ce que je pouvais
apporter, je change
si j'en ai l'occasion.
-Jeune pédiatre,
vous avez d'abord travaillé
dans un service
de Protection maternelle
et infantile.
Ensuite, vous avez travaillé
dans un centre de la Croix-Rouge,
avec des toxicomanes,
puis vous avez suivi
votre mari à Singapour
où vous avez aidé
des travailleurs migrants
maltraités par leurs employeurs.
Sans faire de politique,
vous avez toujours eu
des engagements assez forts.
C'est important pour vous ?
-Ah oui. Je reviens à l'image
de la brique dans le mur.
J'ai besoin
d'être utile aux autres.
J'aurais eu du mal...
J'ai fait une préparation
aux écoles d'ingénieurs
et quand j'ai compris
qu'ingénieur,
c'était dans un bureau,
j'ai su que ce n'était pas pour moi.
J'avais besoin de me sentir utile,
d'être sur le terrain,
en me disant depuis toute petite :
"J'ai eu de la chance...
"Je suis dans un pays
et une famille incroyables,
"un quartier formidable.
"Pourquoi tout le monde
n'a pas cette chance ?"
Ca me travaillait beaucoup.
Je voulais rendre
ce qu'on m'avait donné.
-L'engagement
politique avant 2017,
ça ne vous attirait pas ?
-Très intéressée par la politique,
le fonctionnement de la société,
mais je trouvais pas
d'offre politique qui englobe
ce à quoi j'aspirais.
Il y avait toujours un truc
qui clochait,
donc je ne me suis pas
engagée avant.
-En 2017, vous vous apprêtiez
à devenir une autre brique,
encore.
Vous étiez à Paris
et vous suiviez
une formation
de médecin urgentiste.
-Oui.
-C'est là que la politique
entre dans votre vie
avec Emmanuel Macron.
Pourquoi vous vous dites :
"Là, j'y vais" ?
-Toujours dans ce souci
d'aider les autres.
D'abord, en 2002,
Le Pen au 2e tour,
ça me frappe énormément.
Ensuite, je vais à Singapour,
loin de la France,
donc j'ai moins d'intérêt
pour la politique en France.
J'ai l'impression d'être inutile,
je comprends dans les sondages
que Le Pen monte
et je me dis que je ne pourrais pas
regarder mes enfants dans les yeux
sans leur avoir dit :
"J'aurai essayé quelque chose."
Donc il fallait
que je m'engage.
A ce moment-là,
il y a Emmanuel Macron
qui représentait à la fois
l'humanisme,
ce souci d'être au plus près
de ceux qui ont des difficultés,
c'est ce qui m'engageait
depuis longtemps,
et de l'autre côté, ne pas être
dans un Etat coercitif...
J'avais voyagé
dans les pays de l'est.
J'avais des souvenirs
du bloc soviétique, je suis née
à l'époque de la guerre froide,
et je voulais pas de ça.
J'ai trouvé une offre politique
qui me correspondait.
-Donc En Marche vous a investie
dans la 11e circonscription
des Français de l'étranger.
C'est la plus vaste
de toutes les circonscriptions.
Elle compte 49 pays à cheval
sur trois continents,
11 fuseaux horaires.
Comment est-ce qu'on fait ?
On la voit sur ces images,
ça représente
une zone importante.
Comment on fait campagne
sur un territoire aussi vaste ?
-Nous avons le fichier e-mail
de tous nos électeurs.
J'ai une base de données
de 80 000 e-mails.
J'utilise les outils numériques,
qui marchent bien.
J'ai pu voir des gens
qui me connaissaient
que je n'avais jamais vus.
Ils me connaissaient à travers
mes communications,
donc ça marche.
Et ensuite, je me déplace un peu,
pas partout.
Je ne pourrai pas visiter
les 40 sur 49 où il y a
des communautés françaises.
Je me déplace toujours
quand il y a une vraie raison
d'y aller,
pour faire attention
aux dépenses que ça engage,
à la fatigue que ça génère,
à l'intérêt que ça peut avoir
pour nos communautés.
J'essaie d'être
le plus utile possible.
-Mais en campagne,
vous avez fait beaucoup de voyages;
J'ai retrouvé
vos affiches de meetings
de 2017, je le disais
tout à l'heure,
on dirait une tournée
des Rolling Stones :
Melbourne, Sydney,
Hong Kong, Delhi...
-J'avais pas pensé au parallèle,
c'est tout à fait ça.
-Mais il faut un sacré budget avion,
notamment.
Comment vous financez ça ?
-D'abord,
je partais de Singapour,
et on est en Asie,
il y a des vols low-cost.
C'est des petites distances.
Le budget est important
mais pas considérable.
J'ai pas dépensé tout
le budget de campagne...
-Y a pas un budget
pour les campagnes à l'étranger ?
-J'ai un budget
pour les campagnes
à l'étranger qui est différent
de mes collègues en métropole,
mais je n'ai pas tout dépensé,
ni pour la campagne,
ni pour ma mission
de parlementaire.
-Vous êtes, depuis 2017,
l'une des 11 députés des Français
à l'étranger.
La taille de votre circonscription
fait que vous avez dû trouver
une façon originale d'assurer
vos permanences parlementaires.
On va voir ça en images.
*-Bonjour à tous.
Je vais attendre
les premières connexions
pour pouvoir lancer
notre échange.
Nous sommes
dans la permanence virtuelle,
que je vous propose
tous les mois,
et qui me permet
de vous présenter
mon travail de parlementaire,
d'échanger avec vous
et de répondre à vos questions.
Je vois déjà des questions
qui sont tombées
dans le chat...
-La plupart des échanges
que vous avez avec vos administrés,
ou vos électeurs,
c'est comme ça, par Facebook Live,
ou en Zoom
pour les petits groupes.
Est-ce que c'est pas
un peu frustrant pour vous
et peut-être pour eux ?
-Alors...
D'abord, nous-mêmes
qui sommes à l'étranger,
nous avons l'habitude de ces outils
avec nos proches.
On a l'habitude de se voir
par écrans interposés.
Ca fait pas
une grosse différence
par rapport à notre quotidien.
Je peux pas faire autrement,
mais ça ne m'empêche pas,
sur des situations de crise,
de proposer un Zoom,
parfois d'un jour à l'autre.
Si, dans une communauté,
il y a un problème,
je propose un Zoom le lendemain
et on échange
plus directement, facilement.
Ca aide.
Merci aux outils numériques.
-Votre point d'attache,
c'est Singapour.
Comment faites-vous
pour être au palais Bourbon
quand il faut voter les lois,
Singapour et votre circonscription ?
-Le plus gros du travail
d'un parlementaire,
c'est le palais Bourbon.
Mes collègues sont là généralement
du mardi au jeudi au minimum,
parfois dès le lundi après-midi
jusqu'au vendredi,
quand on siège jusqu'au vendredi.
Le gros du travail est ici,
même quand un citoyen
nous sollicite
pour un souci
avec une administration.
Les questions qu'on va poser
aux responsables de ces entités,
ils sont à Paris,
pas en province ou à l'étranger,
donc il faut
qu'on soit présent.
Contrairement à eux,
je ne peux pas prendre un train
pour rentrer le week-end,
donc j'y vais pendant les séances
de suspension des travaux.
Avant, je pouvais y aller
toutes les 4 à 5 semaines,
mais j'ai dû changer mon rythme
avec la majorité relative.
Donc, je dois y aller
la semaine de suspension
que l'on a en octobre-novembre,
les trois semaines de Noël,
la semaine de février,
les deux semaines d'avril,
ou l'inverse.
Je m'octroie une petite faveur.
Lors de la session extraordinaire,
on a droit à une délégation de vote,
donc je voyage
en juillet et en septembre.
-Vous ne pouvez pas
déléguer ce vote le reste du temps ?
-Non.
-Il n'y a pas
de règle dérogatoire ?
-Que pour session extraordinaire
de l'Assemblée.
Ca limite le temps des déplacements,
mais cette année,
j'ai quand même fait
autant de pays
que d'autres années, hors Covid.
-Justement, le Covid.
Comment vous avez géré
vos allers-retours
entre Paris et Singapour ?
-Eh bien le hasard,
plutôt l'organisation de mon travail
faisait qu'au moment
de la suspension des travaux
du mois de mars 2020,
je me trouvais en France.
Avant que l'espace aérien ne ferme,
j'ai appelé en urgence mon époux
pour lui dire qu'il lui restait
48 heures pour rentrer.
S'il était pas rentré,
on ne serait pas vus
pendant deux ans.
-Vous êtes restée...
-En France, oui,
car mon pays, Singapour,
refusait,
même avec un titre
de séjour permanent,
que je rentre à Singapour.
J'avais pas le droit de rentrer.
Des pays ont même interdit
à leurs ressortissants de rentrer.
-Sur vos réseaux,
on vous voit avec des ambassadeurs,
notamment celui de Chine en France,
celui d'Indonésie,
ou avec des officiels
des pays qui font partie
de votre circonscription,
comme le Parlement
de la Corée du Sud, par exemple.
Vous êtes un peu
députée diplomate,
on peut dire ?
Il y a une part de diplomatie ?
-Il y en a une,
d'autant que j'ai été membre
de la Commission
des Affaires étrangères.
Dans ce cadre-là,
je jouais pleinement mon rôle
de diplomatie parlementaire.
Un parlementaire
peut dire des choses
que parfois nos diplomates
ne peuvent pas dire.
Et puis,
dans chacun des pays,
j'ai à coeur de présenter
nos communautés
aux responsables sur place
et leur dire qu'il y a
des communautés de Français.
Ils ne se rendent pas
toujours compte...
-Des difficultés ?
-Des atouts aussi.
Je vends la France
très positivement en leur disant :
"Vous avez des entreprises
qui font ci, qui font ça,
"un chocolatier français,
un marchand de vin..."
J'aime bien vendre notre pays
à mes interlocuteurs
sur place.
-Parfois,
vous donnez l'impression
d'aller au-delà de la diplomatie.
Ca a été le cas
en 2021,
quand l'Australie a annulé
le fameux contrat
où il s'agissait de construire
12 sous-marins
pour 50 milliards
de dollars.
A l'époque, vous avez fait
une confidence surprenante.
On va revoir ça.
*-Un député de la majorité
du Premier ministre actuel m'a dit :
"J'en veux pas
de votre contrat,
"il est trop cher,
je ferai tout pour le déchirer."
Il était très agressif
avec ça.
J'étais si stupéfaite
que je m'en suis ouvert
aux autorités françaises,
et on m'a dit : "Oui, on sait."
"On sait."
-Ca donne l'impression
que vous faites presque
du renseignement.
-Je crois que...
-Vous avez accès
à des informations
qui sont pas encore...
-Pas seulement moi.
Tous les Français installés
à l'étranger,
par les contacts
avec les autorités locales,
les entreprises,
des institutionnels,
on a des informations
dont le pays a besoin.
-Ca veut dire
que vous travaillez en coordination
avec le Quai d'Orsay
sur certains sujets ?
-Toujours.
C'est important
de se coordonner,
de s'assurer
que j'ai les bons messages,
et qu'inversement,
ils peuvent m'orienter en disant :
"On voudrait plutôt avancer
sur ce sujet."
Chaque fois que j'ai
une information pertinente,
je la rapporte.
-L'Ukraine est
dans votre circonscription.
Vous avez d'ailleurs rencontré
Volodymyr Zelensky à Kiev,
car vous avez accompagné
Yaël Braun-Pivet
dans son voyage sur place.
Avez-vous pu
vous rendre utile
sous une forme ou une autre
quand la guerre a éclaté ?
-J'ai eu des contacts
avec les Français sur place
qui se questionnaient
sur la position française,
ce qu'on allait faire pour soutenir.
Au moment du rendez-vous
avec Volodymyr Zelensky,
le sujet que j'ai abordé
et sur lequel je travaille,
c'est le risque
que les opinions publiques
nous lâchent
à un moment ou un autre.
Notre travail, à lui et à nous,
citoyens et parlementaires,
c'est d'animer l'opinion publique
et de ne pas oublier l'Ukraine.
J'espère être utile
en faisant vivre le sujet ukrainien
pour que les opinions publiques
ne nous lâchent pas.
-On passe à notre quiz.
Je vous explique le principe,
pas très compliqué.
Je vais commencer
une phrase
et ça va être à vous
de la compléter.
On démarre.
"Vus de Singapour,
"les débats dans l'hémicycle
sont parfois..."
-Particulièrement animés
et irrespectueux,
tout à fait à l'opposé.
-C'est pas comme ça en Asie.
"Mes collègues
au palais Bourbon
"pensent souvent que..."
-S'agissant de moi ?
-De vous
et du fait
d'être députée
de l'étranger,
on va dire.
-Curieux, interrogatifs,
mais je pense
que je suis souvent vue
comme souriante
et soucieuse du consensus.
-Enfin, "la prochaine brique
dans ma vie sera...",
après celle de députée ?
-Oh, alors comme j'ai encore
4 ans de mandat...
Dans 2 ans,
je ne sais déjà pas,
mais j'aimerais faire des choses,
toujours être utile au pays...
-Merci, Anne Genetet...
-Merci à vous.
-...d'être venue.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA